Suicide rates have been steadily increasing in recent years, according to the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention. Still, stigma and lack of access to mental health services prevent many people from receiving the help they need. In this episode, psychologist and professor Nadine Kaslow talks about what psychologists are doing to enhance the services available to people who are struggling with thoughts of suicide. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. We're speaking with Dr. Nadine Caslow, 2014 president of the American Psychological Association, a tenured professor at Emory University's School of Medicine. Dr. Caslow is also a practicing clinical psychologist. She is here to talk with us today about suicide prevention and how psychologists are developing new and innovative ways to help those who are suffering.
根据美国疾病控制与预防中心的数据，近年来自杀率一直在稳步上升。尽管如此，污名化和心理健康服务获取渠道的匮乏，仍使许多人无法获得所需的帮助。在本期节目中，心理学家兼教授娜丁·卡斯洛（Nadine Kaslow）将探讨心理学家正在采取哪些措施，以改善那些有自杀念头的人所能获得的服务。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），这是《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）。我们今天采访的是2014年美国心理学会主席、埃默里大学医学院终身教授娜丁·卡斯洛博士。卡斯洛博士也是一位执业临床心理学家。她今天来到这里，与我们探讨自杀预防，以及心理学家如何开发创新方法来帮助那些受苦的人。
Thank you for joining us, Dr. Caslow. I'm delighted to be here. Suicide prevention is an issue you feel very strongly about, and it has been a focus of your work throughout your career. Tell us why you have chosen to spend your time helping those who feel they have nowhere else to turn. I think my interest in suicide and preventing suicide began when I was in high school, and one of my closest friends' mothers died by suicide. And I saw the profound impact that this had on her children, her husband, and the community at large, and the pain and suffering that everyone's
感谢您参加我们的节目，卡斯洛博士。我很高兴能来到这里。自杀预防是您非常关注的一个议题，也是您整个职业生涯的工作重点。请告诉我们，为什么您选择投入时间去帮助那些感到走投无路的人？我想我对自杀及预防自杀的兴趣始于高中时期，当时我的一位挚友的母亲自杀身亡。我亲眼目睹了这件事对她的孩子、丈夫以及整个社区造成的深远影响，以及每个人所经历的痛苦和折磨。
else experienced and I believe it was then that I wanted to do something about it. Then when I became, well, when I was in graduate school actually at the end of my postdoc, a patient of mine who I was extremely attached to, died by suicide and it was very, very difficult for me. It was extremely difficult for me personally as well as professionally. I realized, however, that she chose to die by suicide because she was in so much pain in her life. She was in such psychic pain, and she was hearing voices and having visual hallucinations as well. And she was tormented and tortured and profoundly depressed, and she couldn't tolerate living anymore. And so I really wanted to, after that, help people both who are in so much pain, try to reduce their pain in other ways, as well as help families and friends and community cope after someone died by suicide.
我当时就想为此做点什么。后来，当我读研究生时，确切地说是博士后研究快结束时，我的一位非常亲近的病人自杀身亡了，这对我来说非常非常艰难。无论是在个人层面还是专业层面，这都让我感到极其痛苦。然而，我意识到她选择自杀是因为她在生活中承受了太多的痛苦。她承受着巨大的心理痛苦，不仅听到声音，还有幻视。她备受折磨，深陷抑郁，无法再忍受活下去。因此，在那之后，我真心希望能帮助那些承受巨大痛苦的人，尝试以其他方式减轻他们的痛苦，同时也帮助那些在亲友自杀后需要应对创伤的家庭、朋友和社区。
What are psychologists doing to enhance the services available to people who are struggling with thoughts of suicide? I understand there's an app. You and your team have developed called Relief Link. Can you tell us about that as well? Let me talk a little bit about what psychologists are doing. Increasingly, psychologists are developing evidence-based treatments for suicidal persons, people with suicidal ideation or suicide attempts, and developing evidence-based treatments for youth, for adults, and for older adults, as well as for individuals from different
心理学家正在采取哪些措施来改善那些有自杀念头的人所能获得的服务？我听说您和您的团队开发了一款名为“Relief Link”的应用程序。您能跟我们介绍一下吗？让我先谈谈心理学家正在做的事情。越来越多的心理学家正在为有自杀倾向、有自杀意念或自杀未遂的人开发循证治疗方法，并针对青少年、成年人、老年人以及来自不同背景的个人开发循证治疗方案。
ethnic racial groups. So that's one thing psychologists are doing. The second thing that many psychologists are involved with are the Garrett Lee Smith grants. And these grants are given to colleges and universities and tribal communities, as well as to states to develop major suicide prevention efforts. And I believe that these grants have really helped facilitate infrastructures in different settings and have really made a difference in psychologists are often leaders on these grants. In terms of developing apps that can be useful adjuncts or used as a primary tool for individuals who were suicidal,
这是心理学家正在做的一件事。第二件事是许多心理学家参与了“加勒特·李·史密斯”（Garrett Lee Smith）拨款项目。这些拨款提供给学院、大学、部落社区以及各州，用于开展重大的自杀预防工作。我相信这些拨款确实有助于在不同环境中建立基础设施，并产生了显著影响，而心理学家往往是这些项目的领导者。在开发可作为辅助工具或主要工具供有自杀倾向的个人使用的应用程序方面，
the Substance Abuse and Mental Health Services Administration, SAMHSA, put out an app challenge last year and asked for people to submit apps related to suicide prevention. We were extremely fortunate that our app was the winner of the first place prize. And the app helps talk to people or connect people with services, has safety planning on there, has various activities that people can do when they're feeling suicidal, and allows people to develop very individualized plans as well as get help anywhere they are in the United States. How can digital technology work in conjunction with one-on-one therapy? Has there been research in this area?
美国药物滥用和心理健康服务管理局（SAMHSA）去年举办了一场应用程序挑战赛，征集与自杀预防相关的应用程序。我们非常幸运，我们的应用程序获得了第一名。该应用程序有助于与人们沟通或将他们与服务联系起来，其中包含安全规划，提供人们在感到有自杀倾向时可以进行的各种活动，并允许人们制定非常个性化的计划，以及在全美任何地方获得帮助。数字技术如何与一对一治疗相结合？这一领域有相关研究吗？
There's growing research on digital technology, and there's media-related interventions right now, and these are growing, especially for people with medical difficulties. But it is very clear that people in the younger generations really turn to the media, to social media, as a way to get all sorts of assistance. I really think it's important for therapists to encourage people who might be interested to download apps on their smartphones or on their tablets and to use them as they see fit in a way that integrates them with the treatment. Sometimes, for example, you might encourage a patient or a client to use these apps
关于数字技术的研究越来越多，目前也有与媒体相关的干预措施，这些都在增长，特别是针对有医疗困难的人群。但很明显，年轻一代确实转向媒体和社交媒体来获取各种帮助。我真的认为，治疗师鼓励有兴趣的人在智能手机或平板电脑上下载应用程序，并以一种与治疗相结合的方式适当地使用它们，是非常重要的。例如，有时你可以鼓励病人或客户使用这些应用程序
to rate their mood daily or their suicidal ideation daily and agree with them. them that if it gets above a certain level, here's what the safety plan would be, and here's when you might contact your therapist, here's when you might need to call 911 or go to the emergency room. So I think they can be integrated in very creative ways. I also think that a lot of adolescents and young adults can teach us ways to effectively integrate them, and especially how to communicate with them via these tools. I believe that psychology, and psychologists have begun to very seriously consider how to integrate social media and other forms of technology into their work. But I also think that we have a number of other steps
来每天评估他们的情绪或自杀意念，并与他们达成共识：如果指标超过一定水平，安全计划应该是什么，什么时候应该联系治疗师，什么时候需要拨打911或去急诊室。所以我认为它们可以以非常有创意的方式整合在一起。我也认为许多青少年和年轻人可以教我们如何有效地整合这些工具，特别是如何通过这些工具与他们沟通。我相信心理学界和心理学家已经开始非常认真地考虑如何将社交媒体和其他形式的技术融入到他们的工作中。但我同时也认为，我们还有许多其他步骤
that we need to consider before we have a really good plan for doing this in a very effective way. You mentioned young people, and they are very focused on social media and digital technology. There have been some high-profile cases in the media where a young person has committed suicide after being cyber-bullied or harassed online. Is suicide increasing among young people? How do we direct prevention efforts toward these youth? So there's some suggestion that suicide rates are increasing among certain subgroups of young people. I also think that we're hearing more or more about suicides of young people. So sometimes it's a little difficult to tell. what's an actual increase versus what's better reporting and surveillance.
在制定出非常有效的计划之前，我们需要考虑这些步骤。您提到了年轻人，他们非常关注社交媒体和数字技术。媒体上曾报道过一些备受关注的案例，年轻人因遭受网络欺凌或骚扰而自杀。年轻人的自杀率在上升吗？我们该如何针对这些青少年开展预防工作？目前有一些迹象表明，某些青少年群体的自杀率正在上升。我也认为我们越来越多地听到关于年轻人自杀的消息。所以有时很难区分什么是真正的增长，什么是更好的报告和监测结果。
But there are definitely concerns that young people are very effective by what goes on via social media. And things like cyberbullying have clearly been associated with some young people's death by suicide. It's tricky to direct prevention efforts to this, but I think we need activities in the schools and programs in the schools, related to this and related to talking about things like cyber bullying and cyber harassment and the link between that and suicidal thoughts and actions, as well as aggressive thoughts and actions. So school-based programming is important.
但毫无疑问，人们非常担心年轻人受到社交媒体上发生的事情的影响。像网络欺凌这样的事情显然与一些年轻人的自杀身亡有关。针对这一点开展预防工作很棘手，但我认为我们需要在学校开展相关活动和项目，讨论网络欺凌和网络骚扰，以及它们与自杀念头和行为，还有攻击性思想和行为之间的联系。因此，基于学校的项目非常重要。
I also think such programming needs to exist in other places in the community, whether those be religious organizations or other places that young people go for community activities. In addition, the media can be extremely helpful to us here in terms of talking about this, but also blogging about this, having programs that talk about this on channels that kids listen to. So I think there's a number of different ways we can engage more actively in preventive efforts. Also, I think that parents and schools and other settings need to take things like cyber bullying very, very seriously.
我也认为这种项目需要在社区的其他地方存在，无论是宗教组织还是年轻人进行社区活动的其他场所。此外，媒体在这方面可以为我们提供极大的帮助，不仅是谈论这个问题，还可以通过博客撰写相关内容，并在孩子们收听的频道上播放讨论此话题的节目。所以我认为我们可以通过多种不同的方式更积极地参与预防工作。此外，我认为家长、学校和其他环境需要非常非常认真地对待网络欺凌等问题。
because it has extremely negative effects on young people. What are the barriers to getting care for suicidal youth and their families? One of the first barriers is the stigma about getting psychological services. Many people and many communities would rather do anything else than get psychological services because they're worried about the stigma associated with that. So they don't want to see the school counselor or the school psychologist because they don't want the other kids to know that there's something wrong with them, and they feel like they're going to be labeled.
因为它对年轻人有极其负面的影响。获取心理健康服务对于有自杀倾向的青少年及其家庭来说，障碍是什么？首要障碍之一是对获取心理服务的污名化。许多人和许多社区宁愿做任何其他事情，也不愿寻求心理服务，因为他们担心与之相关的污名。所以他们不想见学校辅导员或学校心理学家，因为他们不想让其他孩子知道他们有问题，他们觉得会被贴上标签。
So stigma is one major barrier. The second major barrier is that there are not a sufficient number of psychologists and other mental health professionals who are really comfortable with working with people who are suicidal, especially those who are extremely suicidal. So I think we need more training to help improve therapists' ability to effectively work with young people and others who are suicidal. I think the third issue is that we don't have enough evidence-based services that we have available to us to offer for suicidal people,
所以污名化是一个主要障碍。第二个主要障碍是，没有足够多的心理学家和其他心理健康专业人员真正乐于与有自杀倾向的人合作，尤其是那些自杀倾向极其严重的人。所以我认为我们需要更多的培训来帮助提高治疗师有效帮助青少年和其他有自杀倾向者的能力。我认为第三个问题是，我们没有足够的循证服务可供有自杀倾向的人使用，
and we need to develop more of these. What about suicide prevention and minority populations? Why does this deserve special attention, in your opinion? So I've devoted the last 20 years of my career to suicide prevention in the African American community. Although rates of suicide are lower in the African American community than in other communities, there are different challenges and different issues that need to be attended to. And so I think it's critical that we develop services that are culturally informed, that are culturally competent as well, because we need to have services that really speak to people.
我们需要开发更多此类服务。关于少数群体的自杀预防呢？在您看来，为什么这值得特别关注？我职业生涯的最后20年致力于非裔美国人社区的自杀预防。尽管非裔美国人社区的自杀率低于其他社区，但仍存在需要关注的不同挑战和问题。因此，我认为开发具有文化知情和文化胜任力的服务至关重要，因为我们需要提供真正能与人们产生共鸣的服务。
So we need to know, for example, in some communities like the Native American community, there's often very high rates of substance abuse linked to suicidal behavior. And so their programming really needs to target those linkages. And we know that it's critically important that those programs be done in a way that's very attuned to the cultural issues and the communal nature of their communities. And so I think that people from different races and ethnic backgrounds, people from different sexual orientations, genders, et cetera, ages, all need treatments that are very, very tailored to them. I don't think it's a one-size-fits-all opportunity.
例如，我们需要知道，在一些社区，如美洲原住民社区，通常存在与自杀行为相关的高比例药物滥用。因此，他们的项目确实需要针对这些联系。我们知道，以非常适应文化问题和社区性质的方式开展这些项目至关重要。所以我认为，来自不同种族和民族背景、不同性取向、性别、年龄等的人，都需要非常量身定制的治疗。我不认为这是一种“一刀切”的方案。
Thank you so much, Dr. Caslow, for joining us. You're most welcome. Thank you. For more information on suicide prevention and Dr. Caslow, visit our website at speaking of psychology. With the American Psychological Association, speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢您参加我们的节目，卡斯洛博士。不客气。谢谢。欲了解更多关于自杀预防和卡斯洛博士的信息，请访问我们的网站《心理学谈话》。我是美国心理学会《心理学谈话》节目的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。